Constructed in New Taipei City, Taiwan in 1978,...
...the Sanzhi UFO Houses were a bold move...
...towards an experimental, pod-shaped architecture,...
...quickly becoming a ghost town after being considered cursed.
This increased its popularity as an unofficial tourist destination,...
...which also led to more accidents and deaths over time.
Located in upstate New York, the Willard Asylum has been abandoned for a long time,...
...creating an additional look of neglect.
Old pieces of furniture, medical equipment and even suitcases...
...abandoned when the place was closed, are strewn about.
The atmosphere that the Willard Asylum has is among the creepiest in the world.
Created as part of an art exhibit in 1965,...
...three statues of Christ were sunk to the bottom of the Mediterranean Sea.
Copies were made and one was sunk off the coast of Florida.
Massive in scale, they tower over any person scuba diving around them...
...and remain utterly surreal when surrounded by the whiteness of the ocean floor.